artes co por el riesgo que corren los
periodistas en méxico acapulco fue el
lugar escogido para manifestarse en
contra del asesinato del columnista
freddy román que nadie está segura que
salimos de nuestras casas pero no
sabemos si vamos a regresar no sabemos
que de lo que decimos que de lo que
escribimos puede molestar a las personas
y no sabemos si es nuestra última nota
nuestra última columna nuestro último
reportaje román fue baleado este lunes
en la ciudad de chilpancingo en el
estado de guerrero en lo que va de año
han sido asesinados 15 profesionales de
la información lo que posiciona méxico
como uno de los países más peligrosos
para ejercer esa labor según reporteros
sin fronteras grave y preocupante que
todo el país se siga ensangrentando en
la tarea periodística
guerrero ocupa el segundo lugar nacional
en no nada grato seguro nacional de
veracruz este martes la oficina del alto
comisionado de las naciones unidas para
los derechos humanos condenó el suceso e
hizo un llamado para redoblar los
esfuerzos para la pronta realización de
una investigación efectiva para
esclarecer el asesinato
aquí y ahora
exigimos paz no balazos ni abrazos de
condolencia
las protestas se sucedieron en varios
estados del país todas con un mismo
reclamo que los muertos no sean sólo un
número la ong reporteros sin fronteras
ha señalado que diez de los casos
reportados por el gobierno este año
pueden estar conectados con el ejercicio
de la labor de informar